I don't understand why my hair is
important for this - do you not
understand cosmetology at all hey guys
guys guys we have a special visitor my
turn yeah you play winner I've been
doing some research on common phrases
that I'll need to know and but that Nona
I can't believe she gets to go to
Barcelona I never got to study abroad
Brandon you didn't need to study abroad
I was a global economics major
I thought you studied engineering gender
women's studies maybe if the DBR wasn't
flooded with bones episodes this
wouldn't be so complicated
hey you don't blame it on my bones oh
here is your change the input you have
to unplug a TV for 15 seconds it's the
input you guys just unplugged it for 15
seconds no guys change the input oh it
was it was the input it was the input
hey Brandon
yes Bri needs to go get waxed I need you
to take her to the salon Brandon get
ready we're going to Brittany's poetry
slam you're driving hurry up dude
Brittany yeah alright I sorry you're
doing no bear she always complains she's
the older one she has her life figured
out but she really doesn't she has no
concept of responsibility she has no
concept of how money works
hello hello hey Bri wants to see you
inside
Brittany wants to speak with you she
said she needs help with her finances
and she wants to apologize really really
yeah
I'm so happy that when breakers whole
just brings our family closer together
you know what maybe while she's getting
waxed they can give you another cucumber
mask that was Britney's idea oh yeah
gotta blame it on Brittany I bet then
maybe have some share music playing
there - you'll be right at home take my
car
now Thanks